welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is Mia magic she calls
herself the headmistress of intuition
really she's a spiritual teacher she has
been deep in the throes of evolving
growing and learning more about herself
for the last decade and has really
gotten into the uh the witchy side of
her being she explains off the very top
what which really is all about so she's
just gone very deep into the history of
of magic and of witches and of alchemy
and women and the things that we've gone
through we also get into the powers of
Sex Magic and the powers of
manifestation and the techniques that
you can use to create the life that you
want because sometimes so many things
are really outside of our control and
what we can control ourselves and how we
manifest and so you'll get a great
technique on how to do that so enjoy the
episode please hit the Subscribe button
let me know what you think in the
comments and the bell for notifications
when you want to hear that we have an
episode come out today's pretty intense
partner is athletic greens I take ag1 by
athletic greens literally every day I
gave ag1 a try because I wanted to
nourish my gut health I wanted to have
more energy I wanted to add more
micronutrients to my body I take it
first thing in the morning before I have
coffee and then before I go work out it
makes me feel so good I'm giving my body
the nutrition it craves if a
comprehensive solution is what you need
from your supplement routine then
athletic greens is giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase go to athleticgreens.com pretty
intense that's athleticgreens.com pretty
incense check it out well the first
question how do you travel with your
hats when you're when you're on the road
because I know that you're you're in
France right now right I I'm in Italy
right now we're here in Italy
um yeah I actually just love wearing it
I love freaking people out in business
class you know they're like what the
[__] is this girl doing here you know so
you wear it oh yeah I can't I mean it
folds up if it has to you know it'll
reform it's just made of felt but um but
yeah it's it's like one of my kind of
enjoyable things to just like wear it in
the airport and then people like you
know the uppity people in the plane are
just like
no I get that a lot they're like nice
costume I'm like it's not a costume why
do you like to shock people
foreign
shocking them it feels like giving them
permission you know like I like to live
in honor of my inner child and I love
Harry Potter so much and I see myself
kind of as like the young Professor
McGonagall even in the GPS my work is um
Transfiguration and so like that's her
class it's the one word in the entire
English language that could have held
such deep significance to me in life's
work and so it doesn't feel like
necessarily shocking them it feels like
you know they usually have a Little
Giggle and they're like oh they don't
understand and that's okay but I think
that for me it's really important to
always just like be myself and be who I
want to be and then when people see that
maybe it'll give them permission to be
slightly more of themselves or a little
bit weirder a little bit more
unusual you know the original origin or
the origin of the word word and weird
both comes from the old German wyrd and
it meant Destiny right because as we use
our words we're weaving our Destinies
and when we're being weird we're not
going along with the herd or the flock
which you certainly know about like
dominating in a in a male industry and
you know doing your own thing following
your own path and so that's been a
really big part of my my life and my
work and
just makes me feel better I feel better
wearing it than not you know yeah yeah I
mean I agree with you that you know I
would much rather be called weird I
looked up I was called weird an ax
called me weird and I remember looking
that up and the antonym of that was
conventional and like I couldn't imagine
my life being conventional or like I
would call that boring well predictable
or safe yeah like I would it's a
compliment when somebody says that I'm
weird so I resonate with like go ahead
and be weird yourself
um was there a point in time where you
weren't so comfortable being yourself
and like had a sort of epiphany or a
come to Jesus moment or a breakthrough
so many of those have you had a lot so
they kind of come in waves you know
um yeah I had a really long I almost
lost my arm when I was 16. I was in a
really bad accident and I believe that
that was
um you know when you think about kind of
the Louise Hay we can heal ourselves but
we also are sort of creating the the
pain and the trauma that we experience
in our lives and that's really hard for
people to ex like hear that and feel
that
um when we've been through really
horrible things to say like you chose
this or you did this to yourself I know
that a lot of people don't want to take
responsibility for those things and I
totally understand when we are victims
of other people's abuse then
um it's really hard to say like I did
this to myself but I believe that in
some way right our souls have chosen
these paths and these hardships in order
to form us into the people that were
divinely designed and destined to be and
so yeah I had a really long period of
sleep very long in fact was
yeah like from I went I started I was in
a very hippie private school it was
called Equinox like before the gym like
just like imagination Lofts and camping
trips and like just super Northern
California all the granola like organic
compost pile the whole thing and
when I switched to public school all of
a sudden like I was the biggest loser
and no one wanted to be friends with me
and no one wanted to talk to me and no
one wanted anything to do with me and so
I just gradually but pretty quickly just
started like hiding my magic hiding what
I was interested in hiding who I really
was in order to just be accepted and fit
in with people who
I mean God bless him but I wouldn't
trade lives of a single one and um and
so yeah so that lasted you know from
like 12 years old until probably
like my early 20s and then I I was in my
accent when I was 16 and I did have a
come to Jesus moment then I was on like
a lot of morphine and was like not
totally Lucid but I did have the
awareness that I was meant to help
people during that time and of course
then like I got out of the hospital and
didn't have a functioning arm and was 16
years old and like felt deformed and
disfigured people would like do the
[__] thing oh the girl with the arm
like it was you know it's a hard hard
time to be
um so brutal yeah disfigured kids are
the worst
um and so so my come to Jesus moment
that had happened in the hospital didn't
last very long and it turned into a lot
of anger and frustration and confusion
why me why is God punishing me and then
my biggest come to Jesus moment was
after that I was dating a really
Christian guy and I he would have these
conversations with God he would go into
the other room be like I have to talk to
God for a second and and it was like he
was on the phone with somebody and I'd
be like who the [__] is he talking to
and one day he was like very verbally
abusive and God bless him I love him he
brought me to La and brought me on my
spiritual journey because I was healing
from heartbreak so like so grateful for
him you know how those ones that just
totally [__] you over like end up being
of deep service and so I was walking
down Sixth Street one day and I was like
God the way that the sun Shone through
the trees and the way that the wind
rustled in the leaves and like brushed
down around me it was like God was
everywhere and I felt this visceral like
yes
I'm here I've just been waiting for you
to say my name or reach out or
try to connect with me in any way and
that was my main come to Jesus moment
was like oh whoa God is not some bearded
white dude sitting in the sky like
hoping to smite me for making a mistake
God is every breath and every moment and
everything all around me and every
person in front of me and every sign and
symbol in my reality and yeah and that
was the moment when things changed and
then I knew I wanted to commit to a
spiritual path and really find out what
it meant for me to have a relationship
with God and how I could Converse and
communicate with this infinite ineffable
Eternal spiritual nature of reality and
and that's when things really shifted in
my the trajectory and direction of my
life changed trust me well yeah you have
these sort of out of body transcendental
super spiritual elevated experiences you
literally do change your life from that
going on because you can't come back you
can't unsee it unfeel it unlearn it
unknow it it's just it's immediately at
that point in time everything is
different you hop a timeline you shift
your trajectory whatever you want to
call it whatever feels good to
understand
um so the one thing about that though is
that usually when we have these moments
like
we think it's exciting to have everybody
wants to have a spiritual moment but
they don't realize that when it changes
your life it doesn't mean that it's all
just puppies and rainbows from that
point on and it also doesn't mean that
everything's gonna stay the same in fact
usually it means that lots of things are
going to change like you know who you're
dating or married to or where you live
or your job or your calling or your
friends like so many things can change
so like did you have that experience I I
heard you talking about the the
relationship that brought you there and
you were broken up with him at that
point then or were you together
we were together when I was we were I
was in the like throes of like what am I
doing here why am I with this [__]
guy why have I stayed so long I've
become one of those women I pity
um and so yeah I started asking of
course we did end up moving to La
together
um but you know and broke up like a
month after that but it was uh yeah it
was so it was so perfect and and it was
you know it was deep sadness it was
agonizing pain that that forced me in
those moments to seek something greater
I was like I have to find meaning in
this because otherwise what am I doing
feeling so horrible like I feel awful
I'm sad and depressed I have like
alienated all my friends because he was
such an [__] like you know and and so
yeah I think that that's and that for me
of course like some people it goes the
opposite right some people they have to
leave their whole lives in order to find
who they truly are and what happened for
me was that like leaving my life is what
led me to who I truly am you know like I
I I became like putting on this hat and
stuff you know things that like I would
never have imagined
would have made me my true self but they
did and and so for me it was more like a
yeah it was like this unraveling I guess
it's like that for everybody you know
you unravel the stories and the and the
pain points and the negative limiting
beliefs and I mean certainly and I'm
fascinated by the fact that you're even
here like talking about timelines and
and trajectories and like I can't wait
to hear some of the little tidbits about
like how you got here and I saw your
last little clip with Kaya wrong Jesus
and Mary Magdalene and the truth about
Jesus and I obviously was just on this
uh Mary Magdalene pilgrimage I mean what
an incredible journey that must have
been for you to like be so bringing this
out into the mainstream where like a lot
it's not safe often to to talk about
these things so one I just really honor
and acknowledge your courage for that
because it's so necessary and there's
not enough people in your position doing
that and and for me yacht was really I
had to I had to leave it was like the
Muggle world you know it was like in
that Harry Potter moment where Hagrid
comes and he's like you're a wizard
Harry and Harry's like what and then he
like Taps the wand and opens diagonally
and all of a sudden it's owls and magic
and books that can eat you and like all
this stuff and that was that was like
what happened for me it was like I
wanted to see a magical world I wanted
to live a magical life and I had to
choose that and and it's it's the
hardest Choice every day it would be so
much easier to go backwards and like
yeah watch Netflix all day but I don't
want to I totally agree like I can
remember in the first few years of
transitioning into you know
being more awake essentially and just
kind of seeing things as they are a
little bit more and myself as well uh I
can remember saying the same thing my
friend I'm like wait a second I'm like
if it's mostly misery on this path of
Enlightenment and growth and
spirituality and evolution and all of
the things like why is it so hard why
are we doing this but it does get easier
right question is why then why and I
feel like there's really just such a big
phase at the beginning where you really
are kind of
settling into a new norm and you're
recalibrating and it's going really fast
and it's opening up really fast and and
then you can kind of hit a spot where
you do hit these moments where you have
big life lessons for sure but like at
least everyday life gets a little bit a
little bit more calm because it's hard
it's so hard but I do want to know how
you gave yourself the name Mia magic is
your name Mia and that you'd added magic
or how does that how did it happen yeah
my name is Mia and
um I'd had a an experience I did my
first spiritual medicine ceremonies I
did Ayahuasca and shortly thereafter a
5meo DMT ceremony that like blasted me
fully into that experience of God and
basically like I was dead for an hour
and 20 minutes and fully crossed over
and then returned to my my soul came
back to my body or like the Oneness
became Mia again and you have to choose
did you have to choose to come back you
know it was like everything in my
spiritual journey where it's been
gradual some people have just those like
and they like do one eyeball ceremony
and all of a sudden they're enlightened
like mine has been like a slow climb
every single day and sometimes I fall
backwards and then I just keep climbing
back up
um so no it was what I remember is
returning from the Eternal all and
breathing as the universe so I was like
I was my lungs were nebulas and star
systems and galaxies and and I was the
breath of the entire universe and that's
like the first kind of conscious
Middle Ground return space that I
experienced and then as that happened
like I became one star and then I was
Starlight and then I was like a
Starlight being on planet Earth and I
was back here and it it felt beautiful I
was excited to come back with that new
or you know that remembrance really sure
sure I was just asking because in one of
my experiences and I've only really done
essentially three ceremonies but but two
really
um and one was Ayahuasca and one was um
psilocybin and in the psilocybin I had
to choose to come back so it was like
that's why I'm curious how far because
it was truly like gone bye bye
um why did you do it I think this is a
good question because I haven't I've
talked about plant medicine for you know
various different times with people and
um you know I think it's it's for people
listening that are curious because it's
becoming more mainstream and more
acceptable and and probably a level of
curiosity and the level of of not
understanding so why did you do it like
why would someone go do plant plant
medicine why why did you do it as an as
a as a
base as a point of reference
yeah for me it was I was in a space
that beginning of the
for me that I was
like
anything that came to me I would say yes
I was just open I was like whatever you
want sure you know I've gone to Burning
Man for the first time and then I had
you know just tried sound baths and
breath work and like all of these
different what year was it what year was
this it was it 2013. okay it's almost 10
years ago yeah and um yeah and it was it
was and it wasn't like a big thing yet
it was still coming you know people were
like serving medicine in in Los Angeles
so like it it would it had arrived here
already
um but yeah I chose it because I knew
that it was a path to healing and even
like I in my Retreats I like love to
lead these like Castle Retreats like
going to Hogwarts for the week and
someone just asked me hey you know you
mentioned these rituals are we doing
plant medicine and I said to her no
we're not because my the intention of my
work with Having learned what I have
from the plants and from the synthesized
medicines as well like the 5meo is
synthesized from the toad from the bufo
and I have learned that there are
there's a time and a place for that
there are people who that is their path
and that is just what they want to do
and there are ways to access those same
States in your body through somatic
release and try healing and through
breath work and sound and movement and
chanting and like I my intention is to
integrate the magic that I found in
those States and in those places and one
of my gifts is being able to transmit
that so often when I'm leading an
experience I can kind of send a
psychedelic transmission out into the
field and people will be super activated
but not ever have to take any medicine
and that was to answer your previous
question that was how I got that name
Mia magic is because I started just like
after that that session I just was like
offering magic wherever I could like do
you want some magic do you want some
magic do you want some magic do you want
magic and just like laying my hands on
people oh gee healing and just like
Hands-On and they would have these
massive experiences sometimes it was
orgasmic sometimes it was it was sadness
and and healing and sometimes it was
just Bliss and and someone started
calling me me a magic and it was like in
this at Summit I'm sure you know those
people and and they just started it just
then all of a sudden everyone just
called me that and that was my name it
was actually a nickname
yeah people then just like bought my
last name so then it was just like okay
well I guess I'm gonna be any more of me
and Magic now I love that that that's
cool I actually just interviewed Robert
Gilbert yesterday and um if you don't
know who he is you should check him out
he takes on the rosicrucian order and
biogeometry and um uh like The Sciences
of Carl you are so out there I [__]
love this you are in the rivals I'm
sorry
well you know here we are there's a
reason why we're talking because like
we're both into all this stuff and
curious and you know I I mean I was
probably most drawn in by Your Sex Magic
Talk which we're gonna get to
um
I just read the maglin manuscript so we
want I want to talk about Mary Magdalene
as well
um but there's obviously so much more
and we're not even there yet so um but I
yeah I I just that you're talking about
sending out the uh the magic to people
and you you know Robert's able to put
that in you know scientific
geometric frequency forms of being able
to for you to understand that your body
is always emitting a frequency you're
always emitting an energy coming off of
you you're coming up coming off your
heart coming off your hands and so your
your work hands on
um your the energy the intention of the
energy that you send out that's real
like those those are those are waves and
they're hitting people and so that's
cool you have a you have a good you have
a good power box in there for it I love
that maybe I'll feel that someday
um I'm feeling it already from the from
this but in person I'm sure it's even
more and if you like if you closed your
eyes and I put you into your
subconscious like whoa and then we'd be
on a whole other Journey yeah yeah
tell me about what Drew you into this
pilgrimage and what what what's the what
is it about Mary Magdalene that Drew you
in well
I think that women are vastly
misunderstood and misrepresented often
in not like in our circles in community
which is such a blessing to like be able
to live and have these conversations the
way that we do but often times you know
I'm reminded that we kind of live in a
bubble and I'm like Oh my magical life
and it's so great and I get to wear my
witch hat and go to Erawan and la la and
that's just not everyone's experience
and so for me so many people listening
by the way I have no idea what arowana
is exactly yeah exactly it's our little
bougie grocery store it's outrageous but
like I can wear my witch hat and go in
there and it's super fun
um so
the word for h-o-r in Hebrew where we
get our w-h-o-r-e word means Womb or
cave
and so ahor like
is a womb it's a cave it's sacred Place
caves have all like since time
immemorial been these wombs of the Earth
where we can go and return to the mother
where we can go and be in complete pitch
Blackness like when you go tour a cave
and they've got it all lit up it would
not be like that you would maybe have
one torch and good luck because the
deeper you get in there the less oxygen
there is and then like your fire is
going to go out eventually
so caves were this massive place of
initiations and rights and rituals we
were singing in the largest cave system
in Europe that was so powerful and so
beautiful and so for me I just feel as
you know we started with the word weird
I am I'm a Gemini I love words I love
communicating I really
feel deeply that so much of who Mary
Magdalene is or was in the Bible and how
she's represented in religion the same
as like how witches are represented when
the word means Wise It's like witches
were the doctors in every village
imagine if we treated doctors the way we
have treated witches like it's just
outrageous so I really got interested in
her because it appears to me like so
many other things in our modern society
she's just been misrepresented and she
was very likely the wife of Jesus and
his counterpart in charging and in
utilizing Sex Magic and creative energy
right they're the same energy the same
frequency we make love we make a baby
right it's creative Sexual Energy is
Creative Energy
and so you know I saw the little tidbit
on Tundra so I don't want to repeat
anything for anyone because you got
Kaya's podcast on that but there is so
much for me about
the again the laying on of hands these
like ancient easy simple magic just like
putting my hands upon someone and
generating these frequencies these waves
this healing this change of mind change
of heart
and so I believe that her womb wisdom
and her work as this [__] this womb
Cave of the Earth where we can return
for initiations and for rights of
Passage and for transformation I believe
that she was very much like an awakened
Avatar the same as Jesus was and they
were working in in Union together
um in order to create these Miracles and
then she was just written out of of the
stories the same as like you know
there's so many different I mean we
could go into so many rabbit holes I
know you like Robin holes um but like
the the words in the Bible that have
been changed ruach the word that is used
now for the holy spirit means wind you
know it's the breath of life and we
change these words so much there was a
time there's a translation of the Bible
where if you go back far enough the word
that became
um Witchcraft and like why witches are
bad and evil it was originally
manipulation so there's just like you
know back then before the printing press
which was invented in the 1500s we're
talking about the Bible being written
you know in like the early one two three
hundreds like these different versions
everything is transcribed by hand so
whoever's sitting there whoever's paying
that person to write this down can say
change this do that like I want this to
be like this and the Bible was just
changed over and over again depending
that's why we have like the King James
version because he was the leader at the
time that that version was being
propagated and so I believe that Mary
Magdalene was you know like a goddess of
her time an enlightened woman a powerful
spiritual being who was misrepresented
and and misunderstood and and was
leading rituals and and teaching and
being highly respected until you know it
was no longer safe for her to to be
doing that or until she died you know
that that part there's a lot of mystery
around what happened but for me because
of the gifts that I have always had
um because of my long study of Tantra
because of just like the nature of the
reality that I want to create and live
in it seemed like a very potent
experience to participate in and go to
these places where you know we even get
like it said that the lineage of the
cathars is passed down from Mary
Magdalene and we even get the word
catharsis or cathartic from the cathars
who were these people these Mystic
people that survived until like the
1200s in in southern France and in this
this region where where I am now and and
so you know it feels to me like there's
just there's always just so much Lost
Wisdom and that's what obviously you're
doing too like in such a big beautiful
way and what we're all those of us who
are on this path of sharing are really
here to just help first remember within
ourselves and go through those agonizing
moments and those miserable times and
those shitty [__] days where you're
just like I can't do this anymore like I
don't know what's happening help me and
persevering and pushing through and
knowing that people like Mary Madison
and people like Jesus you know they
dealt with a lot of horrible [__] to to
hold those transmissions for people like
us to remember and then you know send
out and transmit into the world so it
just felt like a really important uh
piece of the puzzle for me as well and
and really because I do also notice for
me like something I've never shared on a
podcast before but um I really do notice
my witch wound which you know we can
talk more about everyone has it's like a
result of magical people and people in
their power being burned and wiped out
from the planet
all indigenous cultures and
civilizations throughout colonization
and and history
but a lot of that shows up for me in my
partnership and I feel afraid sometimes
to like show him the depth of my magic
and like he's the person that's closest
to me and he's there with me all the
time and you know just like little
things a wrong facial expression one
small sentence that he'll say or that he
said at the beginning of our
relationship like these things that will
just stick in my mind and create this
massive fear of like showing up
as yeah as like the queen and the
Priestess and so that was another big
piece of it for me was like I can't live
in this illusion anymore like I am a
Magdalene I am a holy horde like a wound
Cave of the earth designed for you know
transformation and rebirth and and the
most important place for me to bring
that is is into my life with my king
so that like that Ripple that I'm
sending out into the world is pristine
and it's pure and it's in full Integrity
so that was that was really the the
deeper reason for me going one of the
things that Kaya talked about was I
shared the story about reading the Isis
initiation
um and how cold I was that night and she
was like well that's just your body
remembering and processing you know
lifetimes of being murdered for your
magic there are so many of us that share
and feeling like there's more and that
there was that that we have this power
and it's just been suppressed and not
um encouraged or cultivated this is the
time to bring the magic back so
um so thank you yeah it really is
because and it's not a it's not an us or
them thing it's not a men or women or
anything like that it's more about how
do we do it all together because
actually this was said and talked about
in the interview yesterday it's about
talking about the energies of two people
coming together and when you get the
toroidal field moving actually he said
not even at the same time but you you
actually get them going opposite and
they meet in the middle and create even
more like a like a like a Vortex of its
in in and of itself there that can't be
possible until both
are able to fully Express practice and
express what they're capable of so let's
talk more about just kind of like the
cult of Isis and you know the lineage
from that and you know what you know
about that because I was just very
intrigued about sex magic and a
girlfriend had given me the Magdalene
manuscript and I love channeling and
there's channeling in it and so maybe
going into like what about the the the
Cults of the cult of Isis and these
Cults that existed in ancient Egypt and
and I'm sure in other places too
um and and what their mission was
I mean everywhere like really when you
go back far enough like every
civilization has these beautiful
powerful ancient cultural Magics but we
get the word cult or we get the word
culture from these Cults right like this
is how we created our culture and just
really briefly something I want to
mention you said you know it's not about
gender men or women the witch wound
affects men in a totally different way
because they were actually supposed to
protect those women who were burned so
like people really negate men from the
witch wound but like that is outrageous
because imagine if it was your sister or
your daughter or your wife who's being
stripped out of your house and put up on
a pyre or drowned or whatever it is like
and it was your job to take care of her
there is a massive witch wound and of
course like you know men also like
anyone who was practicing magic or
earth-based wisdom or using the medicine
of planets which was the only medicine
we had all right the modern day
um anyone would be killed but that's
just something really important to
acknowledge for any uh masculine
listeners and like women with with male
Partners is or anyone with male Partners
is like really to recognize that it
affects men and and also really good
point you can't I mean no crying no
feeling like all of that it's all it's
just been programmed into us all
differently oh thank you so with the the
quotes of Isis you know I personally I
love so deeply uh just the magic of
utilizing energy as technology right and
that's what Tantra really is is like
energetic Alchemy this Elemental Union
of like breath and sound and movement
through the body and the Sweet Waters
and the sweat and the tears and like all
of the elements that make up our bodies
and and wielding them for our desires
for our healing
and so from my understanding
you know when I went to Egypt and I know
you've been on a pilgrimage I saw you
went with some of my sisters a few years
ago
um I personally you know everything
that's like called a sarcophagus I'm
like oh this is a burial chamber I'm
like that is [__] ridiculous like
those are not burial Chambers there's
nobody being buried in there but there's
a lot of magical sound frequency
technology in there and there's a lot of
really cool perfectly
you know little Whispering moments and
so it feels to me and also you know when
you when you go there
and you learn about how much bigger the
Nile was during that oh yeah it went
right up to the temples exactly so
they're like using Hydro power right you
know they're using water they're using
energy they're using sound and one of
the things that I'm sure you guys went
to the O Syria on that place that it
just was discovered 85 years ago
underneath the sand and these giant
stones that are all perfectly aligned
just like pristinely cut the same as the
Great Pyramids and they're like 150 tons
which is like 300 000 pounds each and I
sat up against one of them
and I love to do this channeled Writing
Practice you said you love channeling so
how I love to channel is I just invoke
whatever the thing is whether it's the
goddess or the dragons or Mother Nature
or the stones in this case and I said I
call upon the stones of eoserion please
write to me through me anything I meant
to receive in this moment yeah and I
asked them how did you get
here and they said they learned to sing
our songs
they learned to sing with us and they
asked us to come and we agreed
and they showed me I didn't write this
part down but they like showed me this
image of people singing and chanting I
don't know if what else may have been
creating Sonic frequency but like
utilizing word and voice and and like
perhaps Words of Power I didn't I'm not
very like Claire audience so I didn't
hear anything I just like saw this
visual of it and it was like the stones
separated themselves from the mountains
there wasn't anything being cut they
just like kind of like stepped forward
out of the mountains and then I was
seeing them like floating and they were
like hovering over the ground
and kind of like you know it's not like
stones walking but you know like moving
hovering over the ground and I always
think about I'm I don't know you don't
have kids right so I don't know if
you've seen Frozen too but I love that
movie and I watch it all the time
because it's super magical and it has
these like Earth Giants and they're
these giant beings made of stones and
covered in Moss and always reminds me of
that it's like the Earth is alive she is
alive and when we
relate to these elements especially like
stones as being dead when in fact they
are just like billions of years older
than us and you see the way that
mountains form and change like they are
alive very much just in a different way
than we are and operating on a
completely different time scale and line
and frame for sure
and so I think that
for me that Cult of Isis and the sex
magic it was all about just an elemental
awareness those stones are like the
bones of your body and the muscles and
the is like the clay and the mud and the
Earth and your hair is like the trees
and the plants and your breath is the
wind and your blood is the water and
there's electricity making your heart
beat in every single moment and so my
perspective on the the Cults of Isis and
really every ancient major civilization
and the magic you know like if you go to
a place like Machu Picchu even this
Christmas here in in the south of France
the last stronghold of the kathar people
that we were just visiting these are
like high ass mountains tall big craggy
like yes there's steps that have been
built but they didn't exist before how
are you going to build a castle on top
of there let's blow you away you see it
and you're like really really yeah
so I believe that so much of what was
happening during those times was the
result of a profoundly different
relationship to the natural world and
the elements then then perhaps we can
even really fathom you're talking about
this biogeometry I've never even heard
that before that's amazing right but
like our bodies are made of geometry we
can connect to this toroidal field we
can activate that within ourselves when
you think about the macular manuscripts
and the black and the gold serpents
winding up and down one another the the
hieroglyphs in Egypt like all these
these pictures and paintings and
depictions of what's possible in our
bodies and you know it just doesn't take
that long to wipe out that kind of
knowledge when the only other
alternative is death yeah
about this like you're dead and so you
know that created a lot of suppression
and a lot of silence and and in the last
you know
2000 years the the true magic of our
species I believe has been lost in myth
and fairy tale are really the only two
places where it's been maintained that's
why some of the work of Carl Young is so
incredible that like myth is describing
our neurology myth is describing our
powers fairy tales were not originally
for children they were originally like
your entertainment that you would tell
around yeah with your family and how you
would learn what's possible for you and
how you would understand your own
archetypal journey and I mean rights of
Passage initiations like there's not
even when women become mothers there's
no acknowledgment it's like oh have a
little you know baby presents and like
let's play games but there's no
acknowledgment of the fact that like you
are one person until the day that baby
comes and you're a different person
after that and so I think that you know
those those Cults Isis isheld the
Aborigines in Australia the dogon people
like they're is Magic all over this
planet and I just think that it's been
systematically erased so that we are
more easily mentally enslaved
you know then we all are just like
little workers who just
well then I looked up the word magic
because I was going to ask you to Define
magic
um and you can go ahead and give me your
definition of magic but I looked it up
just to know the actual definition and
basically it's like it's it's it's
mysterious and Supernatural powers
that is such a [__] definition like
what is that like that says nothing to
me like that's so it's basically like
telling me I have junk DNA you're like
oh so we just don't know what it's
called so we're just gonna call it junk
it's like magic is what we can't explain
yet but it doesn't mean it's not real
yeah there's a what's your definition of
magic
I think magic is our Essence and our
Natural State I like that it's
supernatural but it's not above nature
it is nature
and for me I think that the
the essential nature right now of
accessing and actualizing magic in our
lives is healing it's healing these
forgetfulnesses and these
confusions and these delusions and these
separations and these limitations and so
that that's why that's what my work
focuses on is is healing my magic is
healing magic right there's people with
different magic that's what's also so
beautiful and such an amazing gift of
like getting to be who I am and like
everyone's little spiritual Fairy
Godmother is like everyone's magic is
unique you actually can't Define it
because everyone's is different you know
there's some people who like they don't
want to be on camera and there's some
you know the witches of the of the old
days in the Enchanted wood and you'd
have to find the right spiral of moss
and the right feather hanging in the
right place in order to get to them and
like where's their little Hut to like
find the perfect remedy for whatever
your ailment is you know everyone's
magic is unique and I I just believe
that magic is who we truly are
we are magic we're literally circling a
giant ball of fire on a floating organic
spaceship right now like that's so true
magical yeah when they when you they've
I think they've seen like when you're
conceived in the womb it's a spark
yeah
that's Magic
like what the hell basically it's saying
it's mysterious and Supernatural like
no comprende I don't know it's just
magic you're conceived I mean I think
it's so funny how
we look at ancient Egypt or Machu Picchu
or any of these you know
um
Gobekli Tepe or Easter Island or any of
these mystical places in the world and
ancient ruins that we find and I think
it's funny that like we don't just
realize we lost a [__] ton of info like
yeah like we don't get it there was
clearly another energy entity uh
technology there was some there was
something that is completely lost let's
just go yeah so something wiped us out
and it's just as simple as that it's not
like why I don't understand why we
always try and reverse engineer how the
pyramids were built with like um ropes
and
um blocks and you know you know thinking
you're gonna get them all down the river
on their boats like seriously like on
logs I mean it's just funny to me and so
I think we're just kind of entering
we're exiting the cognitive dissonance
around the fact that we are the Pinnacle
of what's ever been here that's not the
case or we'd understand but we don't so
what um what uh let's talk about do you
want to talk about Tantra or do you want
to talk about witches next ultimately
like they're really the same thing again
which means why so it's just about
embodying your wisdom and everybody's
wisdom is going to be unique based on
their life experience based on their
trauma based on their pain based on what
they've what they've done with that pain
you know did you let it take you down
did you go into the full spiral and like
Lose Yourself completely or did you let
it rise you up you know my my journey
included both of those things right
there was like 10 plus years of just
like deep and dull drums and depression
and darkness and then ultimately like
that's what motivated me to climb out
and so yeah witches I mean we could go
all day on that and what's the history
on witches I'm really curious I'm
learning more about it I mean
um yeah which part do you want to know I
mean well you know I just like you know
having some conversations and someone
being like you know
something like 9 million witches were
killed in Europe and
um I don't know what the time
percentage of the population at that
time
huge what do you know let's go back as
far as you know and then just kind of
like chunk It Forward because
I feel like this is significant to you
know like you pointed out men and women
but especially women understanding you
know perhaps why they are afraid to tap
into their intuition and their ability
to have clear clear gnosis or you know
Clairvoyance or whatever it may be that
these these these skills are are
resonating in our cellular memory and
we're trying to wake them up yeah and
it's not even
limited to like psychic gifts and
abilities it's to standing out it could
have been to be too beautiful it could
be to having anything wrong with you
like a disfigurement or a deformity even
if it was from an accident like that
could Outcast you
um there's there's so much it goes so
deep so one of the main
shifts that occurred
was like in the the foundation of the
Roman Catholic church and so there was
an emperor Constantine who uh ruled like
in the 300s and originally he was chill
because at that time paganism and and
polytheism was still the main religion
of Rome like we're talking about the
Roman Pantheon that is descended from
the Greek that was descended from the
Egyptian right we think about uh filth
became Hermes became Mercury you know
they're just different names they're
just changing language for the same same
beings same energies same avatars
so emperor Constantine was like
okay all of you pagans and polytheists
you guys need to tolerate these new
Christian Guys these like you know
formerly Jews now they're Christians
like they're coming up they're here they
want to worship the way that they want
you guys gotta let them be no problems
no issues great
by the end of his reign
he had completely changed his tune all
of a sudden it was like uh outlawing
paganism sending troops sending Roman
troops up into like Britannia into the
Northern parts of Europe in order to
wipe out pagan people
the theory is is that he was being
funded by the Roman Catholic Church
which at that time started like
confiscating temples so this was a big
thing that was occurring in Rome during
that time right there's like venusian
temples you look at the Coliseum like
Rome was literally built on temples like
the original Roman Empires like said to
be a dis or Emperor was said to be a
descendant of Venus right it's like it
was very magical and they started
confiscating the temples in order to
like give Christians a place to worship
fine great like everybody deserves to
worship okay but then
they started like taking the resources
and confiscating lands and and just like
basically stealing from Pagan and
polytheistic people and then giving that
money to the Roman Catholic church and
the Vatican they gained like sort of
political prowess by like the the 6th
century and then by the 15th century
they were given absolute Rule and then
the Roman Catholic Church ruled Rome and
now like the Vatican is its own country
like all the gold you see like how the
vatican's like covered in gold
gold doesn't grow in Europe
guess where it grows in Latin America
and all that colonization and all that
pillaging and plundering and pilfering
that was happening still at all right
everything most of the stuff in the
vatican's stolen right yeah yeah yeah
and not to mention what's underneath the
Vatican going on exactly and burn the
Library of Alexandria where like all of
the you know we or like so they say
right they say that they burned it who
knows maybe oh they're still there yeah
all the esoteric wisdom that we're
wondering about like all the Atlantean
documents all the like building of the
pyramids is actually just hidden under
the Vatican we just need to infiltrate
um let's go but it's a long period of
history and the problem is is that
um I love that like William Wallace
quote from Braveheart Mel Gibson like
classic where he's like history is often
written by those who have hanged Heroes
we don't know the truth entirely because
the people who wrote the books and have
kept the only records that we have are
the ones who were like doing the damage
what was really going on I I believe and
when you look back into those times is
like polytheistic people or anyone who
had an earth-based religion was relating
to like spirits of place genius Loki is
like a Roman term that the spirits of
place exist that every plant every
animal has a message has symbolism has
information for you this is what my
entire book is about it's like the it's
one of the universal laws it's the law
of Correspondence As Above So Below as
within so without
and so when you are the kind of person
that not only knows how to work with the
medicine which means understanding how
to use the plants in order to heal
yourself you understand the cycles of
the moon so you know how to grow your
food you understand like energy so you
know how to relate and interact with
people
you don't really need anyone you're
pretty Sovereign you can just kind of
like live your life do your thing have
your rituals and like you mean you don't
need the hospital you don't need
governments you don't need all the
different things that they interject
into our life to you know establishments
of control and propaganda and fear
helplessness
oh I love you stop oh my gosh all right
we're just you know I boil frogs in this
show do you know the expression of
boiling frogs I don't but I like it it's
if you throw a frog in to a pot of
boiling water I'm telling my secret on
the show itself but then they jump out
but if you turn the heat up slowly you
can boil them they won't jump out
so on the show we just like to slowly
turn the heat up little by little
and oddly enough it's getting more
popular so let's just keep turning it up
a little bit I love that girl bless you
sis like it's so it's yeah I just am
like so grateful that you're being so
brave because I this is like one part of
the greater sort of industry and world
that you're part of that I have a really
hard time with like that nobody's
speaking out everyone just like oh I
don't want to not get that job and I
don't want to not get there for
preparing like and then you know people
get slammed and canceled for speaking
the truth it's just so crazy so anyways
who they're being and I digress now back
to back to which is being murdered
right
um so yeah so they didn't need the
systems and and then a big part of the
like Church's thing became like tithings
and giving your money to the church and
like you owe the church you know for
whatever the [__] and so then when the
church became the governing body and the
church is the one taxing people and then
you have to give your tithings it's
really just a money game and when you
look at the like powers that be in the
world they're like the top top of the
three major religions of Islam of
Christianity and of Judaism
and like
those three major religions were doing
the same thing like everybody's been
doing the same thing like getting people
to give them money and like you know
suppress and oh it's this one God it's
only this one God no it's that all is
one with God
everything
all exactly like everything is God God
is everything God is this moment God is
the invisible connection that's making
this computer work like God is every
breath and every element and everything
and so when you know that you're
dangerous because you can't be
controlled and again like we were
briefly mentioning earlier the only
alternative was death so like you got
pretty quiet pretty quickly and
that I think is the the big thing if you
spoke out if you said no hey you can't
do this you can't take that land you
can't take my cow you can't tell me I
have to convert
well I had a super cool past life
progression that I did up in Sedona I
was a kaya actually went up for a few
days
um last fall and uh in this regression
um I was like in I was basically like a
Native American in some way and I was
coming through sort of like maybe Nevada
Arizona like and I was heading to La I
don't know it was like la original like
it was whenever La was just nothing it
was just um village and I got there and
I was so proud of myself I was by myself
and I got there and I realized I had a
medicine pouch on my waist and I was
like oh because and it was like a
farmer's market so I was like oh I'll
set up a table and I'll sell my magic
I'll sell my my medicines and so I sat
there and nobody wanted anything so then
I was like hmm and then it became where
I did medicine circles at night with
women and it wasn't that women couldn't
men couldn't come it was just that men
didn't want to come so it ended up being
women and so that went on for like 10
years and then men just weren't okay
with it anymore and they were like
basically it was either leave
or keep doing your medicine and we'll
kill you or stay and stop doing your
medicine and I decided to stay and stop
doing my medicine and then the
regression was like blank from that
point out it was like it was like it
faded to gray I couldn't remember what
happened for 30 years and then I just
died at like 70. and the moral of the
story was you can either die for doing
your magic or you can die anyway from
not doing your magic because you're
you're dead if you're not doing your
magic
oh yeah that's how most people are
living right now you know that's how
most people live their lives that's why
like goes back to that very first
question you asked about my hat and why
do you like to shock people like I want
to shock people out of the [__]
nightmare that they're living in because
that to me is what like muggle normal
reality is it's my nightmare and I can't
I can't live like that so that's such a
beautiful memory to have and and
obviously you know part of the
motivation for why you're you're doing
this and being who you're being because
like
there's no it is hard it's the hardest
thing you'll ever do pursuing your magic
it is so painful and agonizing but it is
the most worth it quest of all time and
you know even like the word you said
like propaganda like that word comes
from the Roman Catholic Church propagary
to like propagate the faith you know
that word was originated by the church
and so you know we just have forgotten
that that we've been programmed with the
only option for survival being like
leave your magic behind keep it secret
don't show it don't don't stand tall
don't be big don't be powerful don't be
beautiful don't be you know a [__]
female Warrior don't be anything other
than like small and even the word
humility
the word humility has been bastardized
by the church like so many words like
the word vagina means chief for a sword
like I'm sorry but this magical [__]
Palace pleasure portal is not for
weapons like this is for wands only you
know and the word humility in Latin
kumos is not a chickpea paste it's the
Black Gold of the forest floor it's that
rich deep soil that is a result of
everything that's Fallen away all the
old fruit everything that's rotted
everything that's dyed everything that's
just that you that the tree has let go
of
decomposing and alchemizing and becoming
that which fuels the future
and and it's changed to be like oh be
small and humble yourself to God like I
am God
I will know myself as an alchemist I
will know myself as when I let things go
they help serve me to grow
right so and look at you look look to
the inside for the answers because when
we don't do that we we lose our footing
we lose our way we are manipulated we
are confused we don't make progress
um we step further away from our magic
and when we turn inward to for the
answers because we are God then we we
make we move forward so like I think
that this is a practice this is a phase
where we're we're learning how to tap
into our intuition and ourselves and our
and and and not come out of this
um make this the strongest relationship
because it's so wise
and it won't fool you it's not going to
fool you to try and trick you I mean
like that should that really resonates
like you your inner being is not here to
trick you
everything outside of you can trick you
I'm curious because you know you said
[__] so let's get into some sex magic I
think that this is an important topic
just because we're talking about so many
things that are kind of out of our
control but what we can control is our
our our manifesting
capabilities and I love the manifesting
aspect of Sex Magic and how to call that
in and bring into fruition the life that
you want so
how do we do that
girl let me tell you it works I've done
absolutely everything was Sex Magic
um and and also
for me there is a deep
support system that can be accessed
through a more powerful relationship
with the planet with Mother Earth with
nature I find that because we're using
the body for Sex Magic and the body is
the fundamental Earthly element it is
this Foundation upon which we not only
we grow but our spirit grows our energy
amplifies you know I personally it's
just something I've been standing up on
my soapbox about a lot lately but like I
don't buy anything from Amazon I buy
everything second hand as much as I
possibly can I know it takes me 12 times
as long to decorate a new house from
antiques as it does from like just
buying everything easily but I just have
this profound commitment and Devotion to
the planet that serves me so deeply and
so beautifully and because our body is a
reflection of her body and vice versa
when we are in right relationship with
the planet when we know we can go out
into nature and like feel the energy of
The Mother We all share and and the
mother who holds us all there is a a
greater support that then is alive
inside of your body
so Sex Magic is literally just utilizing
your sexual energy for magic whether
that's accessing your Supernatural gifts
or healing or amplifying your personal
power or creating a dream actualizing a
vision
how I have learned Sex Magic there's so
many different practices there's Celtic
Sex Magic and there's more you know
Egyptian like I would say that there's a
lot of sound in the Egyptian lineage
when we're talking about like these
Chambers and what the pyramids were
really for and how you know they're all
missing their Benben Stones their their
top activating Stones totally
so like they're not really turned on so
we're not like feeling the same
vibrational resonance even when we go
into them now and also like you know
Egypt modern Egypt is so like the
apocalypse like Golden Age society that
has fallen which is so heartbreaking but
I think that again like finding the the
finding the path like I like to call it
your intuition that's the name of my
book as well and you're you're intuition
your inner wisdom your inner guided
system is always going to guide you to
whatever the thing is that's right for
you so my personal practice that I have
learned from my tantric lineage is about
using breath sound and movement through
the chakra system so you start at the
root and it's red and it's Primal and
it's the Earth element so it's like the
animal nature of who you are and then
it's into the womb or the sacral chakra
this is watery it's it can be associated
with orange or like you know you really
like do whatever you want right follow
your intuition but that's the color of
the chakra so you like swirl this warm
golden energy in that chalice inside of
you which again men and women you still
have a sacral shocker you have that
that's where our our holy Waters right
our Sweet Waters of our our genitals and
our sexual organs all live for all of us
so you tune into like the flow and the
sensual nature of what this this thing
is that you're amplifying you rise up
into the solar plexus chakra again this
is with breath and sound and movement
what is the fire inside of you sound
like what is the what is the movement of
like that fiery action within you this
again the solar plexus is our is our
chakra of action so that's a really
important place as you're doing this Sex
Magic to really follow what your body
wants to do if you want to like shake or
like get super weird then like you have
to do that because that is the portal of
transformation that is the fire element
within us like let me take action let me
do the thing that I'm guided to do so
are you moving then with the feeling in
each chakra you're kind of allowing your
body to move whether it's through
personal pleasure or whether it's
through dance is that however your body
I've done this practice in every
position I've done it standing I've done
it with two hands I've done it with one
hand in all different ways
um yeah and I I was actually celibate
for three years before I met my partner
and I was doing this practice a lot so
um so yeah it is generally like with
self-pleasure if you really want to like
use it to its highest benefit you're
working through the chakras yes breath
sound and movement with self-pleasure or
with pleasure with your partner got it
okay cool so then you're rising up your
heart is is breath it's it's green it's
like gratitude it's expansion you're
breathing into your heart and again like
you can be in any position you can be
laying down and it can the dance can
take you over or like you want to just
be adding more breath whatever it is
like it's such a unique individual
practice I mean I do this in in like
Community with my my sisters and we
actually did finally just do some some
co-ed sex magic recently that's been
like integrated into community and like
I've seen people do all kinds kinds of
things doing this practice like you can
do it from any position any props you
want to use I've seen fruit be used in
really beautiful ways like you just make
it your own and then you you're in the
heart chakra it's green it's breath
again
it's the expansive nature of love like
what does it feel like to have this
thing or to be in this place or whatever
it is that you're amplifying and
manifesting like what's the love that
you feel for it then you go up into the
throat chakra and it's blue and it's
free and like this is a great place to
like especially for people like when I
lead Sex Magic in my Retreats anyone who
like hasn't made a sound yet you can
just feel like then
like all the sounds emerge finally like
at the at the throat and then you bring
it up into your vision and you really
think about it and feel into it like
what is this thing like what are the
thoughts that I have already having this
what are the thoughts that are
completely healed from my mind the old
negative limiting beliefs the like
[__] I don't that isn't helping me
get this and you and you can really
cleanse that with your Sexual Energy
again you're you're lifting this energy
from the base of your spine from your
root through your whole body charging
all of your energy centers so when you
reach your mind
I like to see it as like purple some
people you know say it's Indigo or some
people say that it's already white and
then the crown doesn't have a color
again you get to do whatever you want
but like I love purple it's a very Regal
color to me it also is a combination
when you think about the colors of the
rainbow in the body it's a combination
of the root and the throat so it feels
to me like this blending of like my
grounded foundation and my full
expression and then that becoming the
the
illustration of my own royalty so I love
to like see this purple energy just like
cleansing through my brain and like
washing all of my thoughts and then you
let the pleasure rise up into your crowd
and and for me I love just like
connecting to the Divine connecting to
god goddess Universal Consciousness and
like feeling your pleasure as a gift
from the the goddess or or from the
universe like what an incredible
blessing that we can even access these
climatic States and then from there
with your vision you you know you don't
have to rush right there's no rushing
I'm like in the big groups like I don't
know there's pressure sometimes it's
weird I'm like always the last one to
come everyone's like had this whole like
big giant roaring orgasm and then I'm
like doing it later so you just take
your time no pressure you never force
yourself and then you you in this
connection to the Divine you let this
waterfall of pleasure the waterfall of
experiencing your manifestation just
wash all over you and how I've learned
it from Layla Martin
dear sister
um OG Tantra teacher
she calls it your five senses reality
and that fountain that washes down over
you is what you see what you hear what
you feel what you touch what you taste
what you experience what you smell in
the reality of already having this thing
yeah so I did this for my book deal I
did this for my partner I've done this
for amounts of money I've done this for
programs and all of these things like
I've done this for so many different
things
um that like have all come to fruition
in my life and
um it's really about like truly
understanding what is what's different
if my life here and now looks like this
and my life here and now looks like that
smells like that feels like that what
what are the big things in between and
then at orgasm or at Peak pleasure again
there also isn't like you don't have to
orgasm there's no pressure like never
put any pressure on yourself with sex
magic and also don't do it when you're
like feeling super down because then you
might just like get down on yourself if
you don't orgasm not a good idea you
want to do this like in a high
vibrational State and that Fountain is
your five senses reality it's like the
most empowered version of your
imagination that you can possibly use
and you just let that wash over you and
Cascade down upon you and bask in that
immersive vision and scene as long as
you possibly can and so that's how I've
learned it you can integrate so many
other practices sigils and mirror work
and like with your partner or by
yourself like there's
hundreds of different ways to do sex
magic but that's the one that I was
really utilizing consistently throughout
my time by myself
um that helped me draw my partner into
my life and then um that yeah like
maintaining that practice in my
community has
um been really a huge blessing for my
business because again we're using that
creative and Sexual Energy and like when
you're calling something in from a state
of pleasure I mean the universe wouldn't
make orgasms feel so good if it didn't
like us having them and I think that
like I think that the Big Bang like to
me is like a big Cosmic orgasm like
yeah I mean you're right that's so good
it's it is so good the whole universe is
rocking
um so why in a group though I'm curious
about that
why not I don't know if there's a bigger
reason is it an amplification of
frequency and is it more about
Liberation oh my God it's The Liberation
at least at least for me in my early 20s
like living with roommates and stuff
right like the only time I had ever
heard a woman having sex or like having
pleasure was either like behind a closed
door you're kind of like you're either
at a party or like it's a roommate or
you're not you know you're like not
supposed to hear it but you're just like
sitting in your room trying to just like
live your life or it's your parents or
it's I don't watch porn but you know or
it's porn or whatever and there's kind
of this like I shouldn't see this I
shouldn't hear this I shouldn't know
that this is happening we all have
horrible memories of our hearing our
parents at least once in our life
exactly
I walked in online
well first time I ever
everesters in a circle it was so
profoundly healing to let it be
acceptable to be heard and to hear
someone else like we started doing it in
um during uh this teacher training and
it's part of the homework and so you you
just do it on your own but there's like
a bunch of us living in L.A hey
girlfriend what you doing tonight
um so I was wondering
exactly no literally we became [__] to
do it so every Sunday morning we would
do Sex Magic and brunch you know when I
lead it at my Retreats the unanimous
response is I was so terrified I was so
worried I was so uncomfortable and then
at the end it just felt like the most
natural thing ever it just felt so right
to support another woman's pleasure to
to be there to like amplify it one of my
other friends was like trying to get a
book deal and we all did Sex Magic and
she told us her five senses reality and
then we all did Sex Magic to it like
with with that intention it's about
amplification certainly but it's
it's more about
healing the stigmas
[Music]
to go do did you do Dr Bronner's car
wash at
um at uh Burning Man
so I've heard that similar like
obviously it's not orgasming together
but I've heard it similar that you know
you basically so for those who don't
know I mean this is like a little bit
more of a you know risque thing to do at
Burning Man you don't have to do it I
didn't do it I almost did it the last
day and then it was a whiteout and I was
like I'm not gonna go like shower and
then be covered in dust so but you go
and you get naked and you you go through
the car wash they hose you off with soap
and then they rinse you off and then you
go on the dance floor and they're
playing music and you kind of dance and
dry off and the stories that come from
that from people that have helped like
sort of like Sherpa and Shaman people
through it to like be brave enough is
that these women are so liberated
afterwards and they feel so much more
confident and I think it's because you
know you see how human everybody is and
you know you're you're there's no fears
you're not thinking you you go in
thinking maybe I'm gonna be weird or I'm
not gonna look right or sound right or
feel right and then you realize that
you're all the same are there any other
sort of ancient rituals or practices
that you'd like to sort of call to
attention that you think people should
be practicing right now oh Hallelujah
I'm so glad you asked me that because I
just um was so blessed this is not
something I would have normally Dropped
In into this conversation but I'm really
glad that you asked because I actually
just had the incredible blessing of
participating in a bison harvesting
ceremony and I was vegetarian for like
10 plus years and due to like the nature
of the food system uh my gut just needed
a change in diet and that was really
hard for me I did not want to start
eating meat I saw like four different
naturopaths and holistic nutritionists
and [__] regenerative medicine
doctors and all the people and they all
told me the same thing you need to eat
red meat
and I was like but I love cows like I
don't want to do that yeah either they
die or you die so right yeah and there's
a right way and 100 the same as like
what is happening in our modern world so
I grew up in a hunting family I'm from
Northern California again like my dad
would always go out and hunt and had
like very spiritual experiences with the
dogs you know they like all sit there
completely silently and the duck goes
down and only one dog's name is said and
only that dog goes out like you know
it's a it's a whole process for them but
in this experience of harvesting the
Bison I
I didn't want to be the kind of person
that just eats meat buys it in a plastic
package at the grocery store and just is
like on my Merry way not thinking about
it not acknowledging the animal who gave
its life not caring about the the system
that is you know the same as the
government and the fear and all the
[__] all the propaganda like that's
killing that animal I just like I did
not want to participate in that so this
was just one of the most beautiful
Primal experiences I've ever had I have
so many ancient rituals but this I feel
like is what's coming through so
we got there and he was alive this bison
was kicking up his heels and he was
alive and snorting and and you know
hoving the ground and and he was
released and he was running through the
fields and he ran back to see his herd
he like knew something was up and he's
just running and running around and they
took him down with one shot with a long
range rifle which was such a blessing
and then we all
gathered around him and there were some
Lakota brothers and sisters there who
had sang and drummed and said the
special prayers you know they have
specific prayers for the Bison that
they've used for Millennia thousands and
thousands of years
and so they sang and drummed and prayed
and we circled around this beautiful
being and I got to like
touch his
still wet nose and like stroke his
forehead the way that I would have if he
was alive because I love cows so much I
know that Buffalo are different but like
big sacred cows you know and we all just
circled around him and put our hands on
him and thanked him and prayed to him
and blessed him so deeply
and then we watched his Hive come off
and then like his organs came out and we
like ate the raw Heart Like took like
past the heart around and like took a
bite of the heart they actually ate like
a bite of all the organs
um not all but like liver kidney
testicles like really like utilizing the
whole animal and then everyone who
participated in the ceremony received
like 50 pounds of bison meat after that
and it was just so moving I was weeping
the entire day because part of me just
didn't want him to die
I'm like teared up like you I don't cry
for many things but animals I will yeah
and I he was so beautiful like just
running around living his life on these
gorgeous planes in Southern Wyoming like
as buffalo have done since the beginning
of their species and I didn't want him
to die I would have rather he stayed
alive but
for him to die in the way that he did
and for us to be able to honor him in
the way that we did and then to be able
to like receive that nourishment and
know that that meat that was sung over
and prayed over and that died instantly
and quickly and that lived his life as
he was meant to and that meat is going
to nourish my body and help me heal
myself
yeah yeah like what an energy transfer
and that was speaking of ancient rituals
you know we have lost that and so I
think that any person who's going to eat
meat needs to participate in something
like that needs to see the the impact
and and and take partial responsibility
you know I didn't take the shot but I
was standing right beside him while he
was alive and then right beside him as
he had died and it will change your
perspective I actually haven't eaten any
meat since that day yet it was the day
before I left on my Magdalene pilgrimage
but
I know that when
meat cry I mean like obviously so
particular about my sourcing but
um I know that when it does cross my
path again that my relationship to it
will be entirely different and when I
did eat cow for the first time after my
years of vegetarianism I spent my poor
friend was with me and our burgers were
like so cold
um we're like in Scotland and I asked
like where does this come from and he
said oh see that Hill those cows right
there and I said where's the Butcher and
he's like he lives right down there you
see that house with the blue roof that's
his house like okay great good first
Burger yeah and then I imagined luckily
like the UK's got some great great
systems still going on but
um some of it but I imagine the cow and
I imagine every time I go to the UK I
sing to the cows and they always come
they just like come flocking to me it's
this like full Disney princess moment
that I always have and so I just
imagined that and I just imagined
singing to them and them walking over to
me and I imagine touching their soft
little faces and their little wet noses
how I just love them so much and they
like have their big tongues and they try
to lick you and I I brought myself again
into that five senses reality of that
experience with that level of reverence
and love for that animal and then I ate
that burger and God is blessed that was
the best burger I ever had in my whole
life I tell you what it was magnificent
and so I think that that's you know
there's so many rituals to charge our
light bodies and amplifier to riddle
Fields with our partners and do Sex
Magic and manifest what we desire and
some of the most important rituals right
now are the rituals of reclamation of
remembering our ancient ways like the
original tagline of my business was like
bringing the ancient way to the modern
day and what does that look like so that
so that we can
re-harmonize with this planet and like
those things that are out of balance and
these systems that we have in place that
are that are harming us and that are you
know just raping and pillaging the Earth
like how can we
create more balance within our personal
lives and our communities and our
friendships and and then like allow this
this way of life to Ripple out into the
world and and ultimately change it you
know it's that Margaret Mead quote right
like never doubt that a small group of
committed citizens can change the world
in fact that is the only thing that ever
has
yeah and so we feel like we are the
change that's right you know that's
right I mean and all we can do is
Inspire each person to to do it for
themselves it's like whenever somebody
makes a lot of progress and they're
grateful and they're like thank you for
something I'm like you did it like
maybe you were inspired but man I can do
it for you so that's all we're trying to
do that's all I'm trying to do is just
inspire people to be able to look within
to go how can I be in Integrity in more
aspects of my life and how can I be in
resonance with my truth and with the
truth thank you so much for sharing
those are amazing techniques and
vulnerable stories and really really
strong powerful stories that need to be
told and will definitely inspire people
so thank you for your magic today and
enjoy the rest of your trip in Europe
thank you sis I will
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button